The minions, those banana-loving, dungaree-wearing,
yellow mini-sidekicks from the Despicable
Me movies are back causing mirth and mayhem,
but this time they've got their very own movie!
But can Gru's loveable lackeys actually sustain
their own 90-minute feature?
Well, first of all, what's not to love about
the minions?
They're fun and funny, adorable little mischief-makers
with an irrepressible, child-like spirit.
Secondly, things do kick off well with the
fast-paced film opening at the dawn of time
and the birth of the minions' and then whisking
us through their chequered history as the
flunkies of various villains throughout the
ages.
After globetrotting through the centuries,
the movie settles down in the late 1960s,
which means you can expect plenty of pop culture
references and a fantastic soundtrack stuffed
full of classic tracks including The Doors,
The Stones and The Beatles.
And the Minions themselves get some superb
song-and-dance numbers – and my favourite
of those is from an absolutely timeless Hollywood
musical.
Speaking of which, do stay to the very end
of the credits; otherwise you'll miss a revolutionary
routine from the stars of the movie!
As you'd expect if you've seen either of the
Despicable Me movies, this spin-off prequel
is filled with the minions' trademark babble,
which manages to be both no language and every
language all at once, and provides a good
deal of humour.
And, of course, their lack of conventional
speech means there's also loads of entertaining
slapstick comedy, including a particularly
amusing game of football.
All of which means there's more than enough
to keep children entertained, and there's
enough for adults here too.
London, where much of the movie's main action
takes place, gets typical movie treatment,
with lots of tea-drinking, rain, red telephone
boxes, cobbled streets, bowler hats, Big Ben,
the Tube, and so on, but like so much else
in the movie it's beautifully animated in
its details.
But where Minions does fall down, certainly
compared with Despicable Me, is in the central
villain department.
Although Sandra Bullock does a good job with
the material she's given as female supervillain
Scarlett Overkill, her character as it's written
just doesn't live up to its potential.
Basically, Scarlett's built up as the most
amazing villain ever and yet, although she
does get to kick a bit of ass and we do see
the stacks of loot she's amassed from the
many heists we're told she's pulled off, we
never actually see her commit any crazy crimes.
And, I'm not quite sure why Scarlett would
actually need the minions as she's got all
the high-tech gadgetry designed for her by
her scientist husband, who's played by Mad
Men's Jon Hamm.
But I guess the simple answer is that this
is the minions' movie!
So, to sum up: Minions is full of zany action,
cute 'n' crazy central characters, and fizzing
with energy, despite having a lacklustre big
baddie.
At 90 minutes, it's an enjoyable romp through
the history of what must be the best-known
yellow cartoon characters since The Simpsons.
Minions gets 3 and a half out of 5 Flicks.
Now, what do you think of Minions?
And how do you think it compares to the Despicable
Me movies?
And what would you like to see happen in a
Minions or Despicable Me sequel?
Let me know in the comments below!
My next video is going to be on Pixar's Inside
Out, so look out for that!
And if you like this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button & subscribe for
my movie reviews and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!